لقد كنا نراقب عن كثب بينما
أرسلت الولايات المتحدة قوات كبيرة إلى الشرق
الأوسط إلى القيادة المركزية الأمريكية
التي لا تضم ​​فقط القوات البرية التي يبلغ عددها ما يقرب من
ألف جندي بالإضافة إلى
كتائب باتريوت وبطارية ثاد،
وهي أنظمة دفاع جوي ولكن
بالطبع  القوات البحرية بالإضافة إلى
مجموعة حاملة طائرات مع
حاملة الطائرات Gerald R Ford موجودة بالفعل في
شرق البحر المتوسط، وقد مرت مجموعة حاملة طائرات أخرى
عبر مضيق جالتر
قبل يومين وهي في طريقها في
هذا الاتجاه، وقد شاهدنا أيضًا
المجموعة البرمائية الجاهزة يو إس إس باتون
وهي سفينة هجومية من الألياف وقوات
الرد السريع البحرية التابعة
لوحدة مشاة البحرية السادسة والعشرون أو اختصارًا Mew
على مدار
الأسابيع القليلة الماضية، كانت تعمل في
مياه الشرق الأوسط ولكن
وفقًا لـ  اثنان من المسؤولين الأمريكيين موجودان
الآن في البحر الأحمر في طريقهما إلى
شرق البحر الأبيض المتوسط. أولاً، إنه
استعراض هائل لقوتنا في المياه قبالة
سواحل إسرائيل ولبنان، وهي
رسالة واضحة إلى إيران ووكلاء إيران بعدم
التدخل و  تلك الرسالة التي
رأيناها مذكورة بوضوح من الرئيس جو
بايدن في
سلسلة الأمن القومي الأمريكي بشكل أساسي، لكن ميو
أن قوة الرد السريع البحرية
تخدم أيضًا غرضًا آخر، فهي
قادرة على العمليات الخاصة وهو أمر
ملحوظ بالتأكيد ويستحق التذكر
ولكنه أيضًا  قوة حاسمة في
عملية إخلاء غير مقاتلة أو
نيو هي إحدى مهام
مهمتها الأساسية الآن. قالت الولايات المتحدة الأسبوع الماضي إنه
لا يوجد مؤشر أو تنفيذ لعملية
إخلاء جديدة في الوقت الحالي، لكن جون
كيربي المتحدث باسم مجلس الأمن القومي
قال إنها ستفعل ذلك.  من غير
المسؤول وغير الحكيم عدم التخطيط
لعمليات طوارئ بما في ذلك
الإخلاء منذ أن قال إن الولايات المتحدة
قالت إن خطر انتشار هذا الصراع
في الغرب على نطاق أوسع في المنطقة يتزايد
ويظل اعتبارًا جديًا للولايات
المتحدة في هذه الأثناء، وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية
نصحت سفارة الولايات المتحدة في بيروت الأمريكيين
بالمغادرة الآن قبل أن تبدأ الأزمة
هناك. كان هناك بعض الاتصالات
بين إسرائيل وحزب الله على طول
الحدود الإسرائيلية اللبنانية، ولم
يتصاعد الأمر كثيرًا ولكن هناك أي اتصال
أي تبادل لإطلاق النار على تلك الحدود
المضطربة بالفعل.  كما هو
جدير بالملاحظة بالتأكيد، وهذا ما
تراقبه الولايات المتحدة لترى ما إذا كان ذلك سيتصاعد
إذا حدث ذلك، فهذه هي المواقف
التي يمكن أن تخرج فيها الأمور عن السيطرة بسرعة،
وحيث يمكن للصراع في غزة الذي
تحاول الولايات المتحدة أن تبقيه منفصلاً أن يتصاعد
بسرعة.  انتشر العنف إلى بقية
المنطقة لذلك ربما يكون أحد
الأسباب هو وجود قوة الرد السريع البحرية
في حال نظرت الولايات المتحدة إلى
الوضع ونظرت إلى إمكانية ضرورة
الإخلاء إذا
تدهور الوضع أورين ليبرمان
سي إن إن في ال
خماسي الاضلاع